uh let's read this news you may have
heard wow amazing from timcast.com biden
urged afghan president to change the
perception of taliban's imminent victory
reuters reports new details are emerging
from the final phone call between u.s
president biden and the afghan president
ashraf ghani with reports claiming biden
urged the foreign leader to change
perceptions that the taliban was winning
the war the call took place on july 23rd
on august 15th ghani fled the
presidential palace and the taliban
entered kabul since then tens of
thousands of desperate afghans have fled
and 13 us troops have lost their lives
scores of afghan civilians
here's a quote from biden i need not
tell you the perception around the world
and in parts of afghanistan i believe is
that things are not going well in terms
of the fight against the taliban and
there is a need whether it's true or not
there is a need to project a different
picture
we will provide we will continue to
provide close air support if we know
what the plan is biden tolgani you
clearly have the best military you have
300 000 well-armed forces versus 70 to
80 000 and they're clearly capable of
fighting well
so it sounds like a lot of lies coming
out of the white house in these past few
weeks so we didn't know was going to
happen they knew it was happening then
on july 1st they abandoned bagram air
force base that's been like the the
center piece of this big story and the
scandal as to what went down because
they didn't just hand off
they didn't here's what should have
happened in my opinion and you know
maybe i'm wrong cause i'm not a military
guy the binding administration could
have said all right it's currently uh
may
by july 1st we will leave which gives us
a month to get in some afghan security
forces afghan national you know army to
start replacing the people who run the
air force base so that you can properly
take it over have the logistics and then
start dealing with the taliban should
they come in after we leave
instead
in the middle of the night on on july
1st they turned the lights off cut the
power and fled without telling anybody
and civilian looters busted in and then
when the afghan army found out they went
in and tried and secured it and arrested
people but you got to imagine
by july 23rd about three weeks before
the fall of kabul when the president of
afghanistan is like yo biden we need
some air support they already abandoned
the air force base without telling them
and bad is like hey we'll provide you
with their support just keep telling
everybody you're winning
so to me
kind of sounds like the plan man
it's indeed the plan but you gotta
wonder that's the plan from biden's
perspective you gotta wonder how where
the lies start right does the lie start
all the way down with yeah we just
trained these four new recruits to the
afghan security forces and they're great
they're doing a great job and those lies
just multiply and add up and build up
and add up and build up to where joe
biden is like hey we really have 300 000
troops there they're really gonna be
helpful for you you're fine three
hundred thousand versus eighty thousand
it's fine i mean that's the intel that
he's getting look i am not a joe biden
fan i'm not defending joe biden the guy
needs to be put into a nice comfortable
rocking chair with a blanket over his
lap nice book in his lap if he can read
and a cup of tea in the whole thing
so let me pat him on the head every once
in a while tuck him in wipe his nose
sponge bands
i'm not volunteering or sticking that on
anybody but like it's it's it's
compounding lie after lie after lie
after lie after lie after lie after lie
after lie
and you know really the president is a
guy that's up there playing risk you
know he's got the board he's got the
pieces he can only depend on the
information that he's been giving and
it's from my perspective it seems like
the entire military industrial complex
is just filled with liars scoundrels and
thieves who are not doing their job but
they want war right that's what i'm
saying so i
you are you saying that you know biden
wanted to withdraw and so they it's the
military industrial complex that screwed
it up and gave them bad info or i think
that that when you've got biden and his
team and the wokefied apparatus that's
now taking over everything their focus
is always on the wrong thing they're
always focused and they're putting their
attention on the wrong thing so whenever
they take action it's the wrong action
because their focus is on wokeness it's
on you know making sure that the uh what
my words i can't say over here making
sure that the army is diverse enough
making sure that they're dealing with
white rage and these things and and
they're not making sure that the facts
and the information that they're getting
are accurate and so they're just taking
these things at face value basically you
can't take anything at face value
anymore nothing but is it lies or is it
collapse right so i'll put the rot
imagine the military is a bunch of you
know you ever see that meme where it's
like two people standing on a cliff and
it's like a beautiful city and they're
hugging and then holding the cliff up as
a bunch of soldiers that are like
bleeding and one guy's point a gun and
they're holding it up yeah it's making a
point about how this comfort and this
luxury is based on it so imagine that
support structure of all of these dudes
holding up society not that i'm a fan of
the afghan war by stretching the
imagination but you start corrupting and
rotting those those support beams and
they start just writhing and falling and
collapsing and then eventually the
structure loses support the whole thing
falls down yep so is it is it really
lies or is it here's the way i see it um
and i'll and i'll do a side note here we
got a video remove we got a strike on
tick tock
because i'm tick tock on tick tock
because i said in a video
it's clear biden is in charge
that there no there are no adults in the
room and that when biden's talking in
these meetings and says stuff people
just go along with whatever he says and
don't challenge him he's got sycophants
and bureaucrats who don't want to stick
their neck out and biden's clearly not
with it and so we got to strike for that
but but i stand by that i think what's
happening is you've got you know kamala
and millie you know uh other people
right the national security advisor
you've got jen sackey and they're like
i'm not saying anything it's like joe
biden walks in he sits down and we heard
him say trinidad a shop at a pressure on
tv what do you think he's saying in
private right when he's sitting there
and they're all sitting around him and
he's like
cowboy commercial but then
do it and they're like uh
whatever you say joe and they just walk
out shrugging we know one of the things
he says in private which is uh hey
leader of afghanistan lie to the world
yeah
i mean it was when he said whether it's
true or not yes whether it's true or not
just lie lie if you have to but treat
people do you wish anything would have
gone differently in afghanistan yeah i
wish the president wouldn't have fled
you know
this whole like crap
it's like they didn't want to hurt the
taliban's feelings we had an outdate by
september 1st or august 31st what you do
as a military if you're not prepared to
leave a war that you're winning
you extend the deadline were we winning
yeah we were dominating that country we
controlled the country we had a total i
had air support we had we had i don't
know logistics we had total
opportunity to withdraw safely
everything over time
and they just chose to surrender biden
surrendered when we were winning the war
he didn't just issue a white piece and
walk away he surrendered our equipment
i actually agree i agree with i i think
so i agree yes in in that in that sense
i would say there when i say i don't
know if we were winning it's like it's
20 years in attrition and soldiers are
dying every year and there was some
serious attacks the past few years and
i'm like i don't know if it's winning if
we're in a country we don't need to be
in to colonize our nation build from
people who don't want us to be there i
don't know what we're trying to win
other than invading this country but
from what you're saying in that in that
sense yes
we
not only did we have control of the
country but we did have the afghan
national army and i think this story is
the perfect example of how it all broke
it's the it's it's amazing it's the
breaking point it's almost like there
really was a system in place not a good
one i still believe there would have
been chaos and conflict but it's like
joe biden the administration made sure
to find the one support beam they could
strip out to make sure it all went smack
down and collapse on the way out they
they pulled logistics and air support
they abandoned the air force base around
kabul or bagram near kabul
they couldn't do evacuations it really
felt like of all of the things they
could have done they did quite possibly
the worst thing i guess the worst thing
would be to bomb your own you know like
the civilians okay so in the sense of
strategy for the withdrawal this was the
worst thing they could have done yes a
premature surrender in getting the
withdrawal executed sure there was a lot
of tactical and operational errors for
sure but like we were losing that war
the minute we started well it's not a
war with a with a valuable goal i don't
think i think it was a pointless
endeavor but we were dominating in force
we were winning the forces but were we
really though cause the whole point i
guess well not the whole point but one
of the points of being there was to
build up this army that was going to be
able to defend afghanistan from all
these other bad guys and in the very
first possible moment
where they were there to do the job that
they were trained for they didn't just
do the job poorly
they just said
just kidding we're not even doing it oh
but there's so i i
i agree disagree uh i think they
certainly did a poor job but
there's a video of afghan uh commandos
fighting back defending you know
territory from the taliban and they run
out of ammo and the taliban comes in so
they drop their guns and taliman
executes them there's video of this
happening they post it taliban wants to
post their victories right you have joe
biden abandoning bagram in the dead of
night
without telling them right so it's like
if you've got
you're you're a country that's been
built up by 20 years of occupation
america comes in they build up this
whole apparatus in afghanistan and they
say it's our air base here's what we're
gonna do here's the logistic here's the
contractors and you're like okay i guess
and there's no handoff of power and then
all of a sudden one one day
the taliban is storming in because
you're pulling out and you're like all
right let's go where's our air force
nobody's there what do you mean nobody's
there right they they did fight right
and not every single one
we had afghan national army defending
the kabul airport and i think you know
initially this was my mistake too when
biden came out and said you have afghan
uh you know uh security forces unwilling
or he said why should we send the next
generation of americans to fight a war
the afghans are not willing to fight
themselves and i was like it's a good
point and then i started reading the
reports i started reading the the the
experts reading the timeline of events
and i was like yo that's brutal some of
these guys did fight really really hard
but biden pulled support on july 1st
sure sure so so i'm sure some of them
were definitely you know died in the
world true believers afghan army
fighters wanting to defend themselves
and their country from the taliban but
if you take it a couple of other data
points one the pew study that says 99 of
afghanistan citizens want to have sharia
law enacted and you contrast that with
our efforts to to to take afghanistan
into modernity by teaching them gender
studies
by trying to actually you know encourage
homosexuality and all these things and
and and women's rights and yada
the culture the culture culture clash
thinking of that cohen brothers movie
culture crash uh the culture clash uh
there was irreconcilable and and the
civilizational clash was irreconcilable
and though and it's one last point the
whole american military machine
is supported by this enormous logistics
infrastructure right air support
weapons and development research and
development supply chains manufacturing
all these things
and they trained apparently and i'm not
an expert but i do talk to many uh they
train the afghan army to operate the
same way that the united states military
does which requires this gigantic
infrastructure behind it right and so
the minute you pull that infrastructure
out well then of course it's it's stupid
it's like it's like it's like giving the
whole afghan army a bunch of teslas to
drive and then then taking away the
electricity
did you see that that's actually a
really good metaphor there's a photo i
don't know if it's real or not but it's
a taliban guy pointing a gun a bunch of
civilians who are like shocked and
scared and they're standing up against a
wall of like the un security goals or
whatever i don't know if that's true
because it's awfully convenient but i'm
like it was a convincing photo
nonetheless and it was like here's our
sustainability goals you know or
whatever they plan they got the website
taliban's all about the memes these days
i hear posting memes they're killing it
on twitter dude killing it on twitter
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you